today on the matt walsh show a racial
equity activist group is apparently
calling on white liberal families to
pledge that they won't send their kids
to ivy league schools and in fact
given that white liberals agree that
white privilege and systemic racism
exists
the group actually has a point also we
have our five headlines including tucker
carlson getting accosted by a deranged
leftist weirdo while out with his family
the olympics begins and nobody really
notices and aoc offers a defensive
critical race theory that contradicts
the usual defense of critical race
theory that we're given and our daily
cancellation i must today once and for
all i i'm afraid i have to tell you
cancel the free brittany movement that
is canceled today along with much more
on the matt walsh
[Music]
you know there are a few things more
humiliating or
degrading than
giving money to someone who hates you
and that's what a lot of us are in the
position of doing so often as customers
and consumers we're buying products from
companies that hate our guts uh well
when you find a company that supports
you and is on your side that's all the
more reason to support them and that's
what charity mobile is all about charity
mobile is the pro-life phone company
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice and that's important
point because it's not just that they're
saying the right things the fact is
they're putting money with their money
where their mouth is
and they're actually supporting what is
the most important cause in our culture
the pro-life cause a lot of great perks
that come with this service as well
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping there's no
contracts there's no termination fees
and there's no risk with a 30-day
guarantee another thing that i like is
that charity mobile is creating jobs
here in the united states they've got
live customer service base right here in
the usa
and free usage alerts free apps to
monitor usage a lot of great perks but
the main thing is you're helping to
build a culture of life in america by
supporting a pro-life phone company so
call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
you know one of the difficulties of
living in a country where half of the
people have gone entirely insane is that
it's hard to tell what's real and what
isn't it's easy to get suckered by
trolls and satirists because the troll
and the satirist
can't present a version of reality any
more absurd
than the one we actually live in so it's
kind of
it's anyone's guess what's real and what
is it and that's why um that's why i
present the following story with some
trepidation
relatively sure that it's real but i can
never be completely sure
so on twitter over the weekend
conservative commentator kathleen
mckinley posted a screenshot of um
of a letter
that was apparently distributed by two
white families in a wealthy suburb of
dallas
by some kind of racial activist group
they went around giving this letter to
white families in this
wealthy liberal neighborhood
the post-millennial has some of the
details here it says dallas justice now
a racial equity advocacy group has been
actively campaigning to convince wealthy
white liberal families to not send their
white children to ivy league schools or
other top 50 collegiate institutions so
that admission spots are available for
people of color to quote correct
historical wrongs an organization
reporting to be a racial justice group
has been sending letters informing white
affluent democrats about the college
pledge around dallas's richest
neighborhood richest neighborhood such
as storied highland park
and then and then here's some of the
what the letter actually says and this
again was in a screenshot uh this was
left i don't know put under people's
doors or in their mailbox i'm not sure
and the letter says
quote we are writing to you because we
understand you are white and live within
the highland park independent school
district and thus benefit from enormous
privilege taken at the expense of
communities of color you live in the
whitest and wealthiest neighborhood in
dallas whether you know it or not
you earned or inherited your money
through oppressing people of color
however it's also our understanding that
you're a democrat and supporter of the
black lives matter movement which makes
you one of our white allies and puts you
in a position to help correct these
cruel injustices we need you to step up
and back up your words with action and
truly sacrifice to make our segregated
city more just
the letter then asks rather demands i
should say that they pledge not to send
their children to an ivy league school
or any school listed in the top 50 by
u.s news and world report
generously
the group does admit
that this is a tough commitment to make
but they point out that if you're going
to have a black lives matter sign in
your yard
you ought to be ready to make these
kinds of sacrifices
the post-millennial has a little bit
more they say on the group's website
white parents can take the pledge online
the pledge form asks users
reading it says will you will you take
the college pledge there are two options
available for users to choose here are
the two options you can take the college
pledge that's the question two options
i am a racist hypocrite or i agree
it says talk is not enough commit
yourself towards taking action and
making sacrifices to correct centuries
of injustice the pledge's description is
trucks open up spaces for black and
latinx communities by refusing to send
your kids to ivy league and u.s news
world report top 50 schools and
encourage friends neighbors and family
members to do the same
imagine if those hundreds of thousands
of spots at these institutions were
occupied only by marginalized
communities
imagine the opportunities we can achieve
true
equity within our lifetimes but only if
white folks
are willing to sacrifice their
privileges
uh and then a little bit of the pledge
is as a white person with privilege both
from my whiteness at maine and my
neighborhood i recognize the need to
make sacrifices for the purpose of
correcting hundreds of years of murder
slavery discrimination and lack of
educational and economic opportunities
perpetrated upon people of color
okay if this is a i should say if this
is a troll job
it's a pretty committed one because i
looked at the website myself and it
certainly appears legitimate the group
also has a very active twitter presence
which includes
this video which i'll play for you from
a member a member of the group named
jameel recorded this video here she is
explaining
why they're asking white families to
clear the deck and keep their kids out
of our nation's top schools here it is
we are fighting for change
we are fighting for equality
we are
wanting to bridge gaps and we just want
to catch up
i am a parent myself and i would love to
be able to send my children to college i
feel that not only sending my children
to college would not just be a good
thing for them a good thing for us but
also in the future to come their kids
will say hey mom dad went to college i'm
going to do that too
therefore i will be creating
generational wealth in my family and i
believe it's a trickle-down effect the
kids in the community the kids that come
over and play the kids that will come
and come over and play with my kids kids
they'll all be affected by that because
they'll see it they'll see it
they'll feel it
i believe that it is my
burden it is our burden to use our
voices our platforms to spread awareness
to offer options and
choices on how others can support the
cause on how others
can make the dream become a reality
so again we're just a non-profit
advocacy group
seeking change
seeking quality
seeking justice
that's it
that's all they're seeking change
equality justice
and for you to totally debase and submit
yourselves to them and their authority
and their power that's it
that's all
is that too much to ask really
take opportunities away from your own
kids and give those opportunities to
their kids
prioritize their kids over your own
that's it
it's pretty reasonable
there is an undeniable poetic justice in
this white liberals thought that the
black lives matter sign in the yard
would be like the lamb's blood on the
door signaling that the blm mob should
pass them over and go visit the maga
house down the street instead but that's
not what happened instead the mob
knocked on their door and said so you're
an ally huh well now prove it
there are a number of important lessons
to be learned here one is the familiar
lesson that no amount of
self-subjugation and self-flagellation
will ever be enough they will always
come back wanting more
uh and
another
lesson related to the first is that
the left and this is really important to
understand
the left-wing mob
has of course a lot of cultural and
institutional power that you can't do
anything about
directly right that's that's the world
that's the culture we're living in
but beyond that
much of the power it has
over your life
you know that power the direct power it
has over your life
the power to control and intimidate you
much of that power has to be granted to
it by you
okay if you allow the labels
bigot racist homophobe transphobe sexist
etc
to bother you
to make you curl into a ball
in the fetal position
you know cowering on the floor when
someone says that to you
then you have given them near unlimited
power over your life
if it really really upsets you when
someone calls you a bigot and the worst
thing in the world to you is to be
called a bigot or a racist
then
because of that attitude on your part
you have given the left-wing mob
complete power over you
you've given them everything you've
given them your soul
you're you're just a dog on a leash now
and then they're holding the other end
of the leash
on the flip side of that
if you get to the point where the labels
mean nothing at all
where it makes no difference what they
say to you or about you
then a significant amount of their power
will be taken from them and given back
to you
see
they wouldn't bother leaving this letter
on my doorstep one because i wouldn't
send my kids to an ivy league school
anyway
i love my kids too much to do that to
them
but two because because i don't care
what they say or think
so if they if they come to me and say do
this thing that we want or we'll call
you racist
i say well call me racist then what do i
care
i don't care
do you agree or are you a racist see for
a lot of liberals that's
you've beat them
that trick right there the false
dichotomy you beat them you can do this
thing we want or you could be a racist
those are the two options
you know fork in the road
go left and uh it's what we want and
that's good go right and you're a racist
see i meet that fork in the road and i
say well i'll just go right
oh you're saying you're racist no i'm
saying i don't care what you say so it
doesn't matter to me
i'm gonna i'm gonna make the decision
that i want to make doesn't matter to me
what you say
now as for these families these nice
white liberal progressive enlightened
families they've set the precedent and
it's a precedent of self-debasement
in fact really dallas justice now
has a point
these white liberals in theory
agree that white privilege exists
they agree that systemic racism is real
they agree that white people are
historically evil and oppressive um they
agree that we live on stolen land
if you were to go up to them and ask
them do they agree with all those
propositions they would say yeah
absolutely
and they and they would keep going so
you agree white people are evil they
don't know yeah oh yeah we're terrible
white people are the worst
you agree that uh all the things that
you have in your life it's it's just
it's just systemic racism has given this
to you
yup sure absolutely
well if you agree with all those
propositions
then indeed you probably should keep
your kids out of the ivy league schools
i mean you should go further than that
you should vacate not only the school
but your property your home
flee into the wilderness in shame exile
yourself
you know you could
live in the cavity of a hollowed-out
tree eating bugs and mushrooms for the
rest of your days
that's what you would do if you took
that world view seriously
that everything you have
is in some way
uh the result of racism and privilege
and theft
that you also in some way are
responsible for and hold guilt because
of
if you really believe that
then that's what you would do
but these white liberals they don't do
that
because they'd prefer to virtue signal
and hope that nobody ever asks them
to do anything more than that
now let's get to our five headlines
one of the problems with uh having car
trouble if you need a car part
it means if you want to go to the auto
parts store and get the part you need
well you might need your car to do that
and that could create it that could
sometimes create a conflict
and even if you're able to get to the
auto parts store why bother with that
it's summertime it's beautiful out well
it's not beautiful here it's scorching
hot so that's even more reason why leave
your house where you can just stay at
home
get your phone out get on your computer
and go to rockauto.com rockhotter.com
has the lowest prices possible and they
also have a great selection
all you got to do is go to rockauto.com
you could see all the parts that are
available for your vehicle you could
choose the brands the specifications the
prices you prefer that's a really nice
feature as well because the price i
prefer is like the lowest one all the
time and so i can just plug that in and
i can immediately find what i'm looking
for look they're a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years so you can
go to rockauto.com right now to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers so do that go right now
rockauto.com see all the parts available
for your car or truck and as always
write walsh in their how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
this was wonderful i have to start with
this
uh
i got to mention michael bennett senator
bennett he tweeted this out
over the weekend and it's a picture of
him he's a democrat obviously picture of
him standing you know uh
in his in a farm
allegedly a farm but sitting next to
some sort of tractor
and uh and the caption says president
biden tracked me down in the north fork
valley to talk about the child tax
credit and so he's posing there on his
phone standing next to a tractor
and i i can imagine how that
conversations go hey joe i was just out
here plowing the fields in my
dry-cleaned uh button-down shirt my
brand new jeans
fortunately my staffer was following me
around taking pictures because i always
bring him with me he's got the camera
ready when i'm when i'm out in the
fields he just follows me everywhere
even out on the farm oh no no my tractor
doesn't leave tire marks and there's no
dirt on the tires either it's more of a
hovercraft actually
anyway what was that about the child tax
credit
i also love tracked me president biden
tracked me down no he called your phone
you had in your pocket
you understand how cell phones work
don't you
somebody calls your phone and you pick
up how did you track me down how'd you
know where to find me
probably the phone you're carrying
around
these people are such posers just
if you're a politician just embrace it
you're a career politician you've been
doing this forever
you're not you're not one of the normal
folk you don't work on the farm
embrace that
be real with people because this kind of
thing
who exactly is this supposed to appeal
to
is my question
i also have that question about the
olympics which started on friday uh it's
big opening ceremony
and
ratings are way down nobody's really
watching it
of course we're doing the olympics a
year later because of covid and now
there's there's no there's no there's no
real audience either for many of these
events
which gives it
kind of a weird muted tone already
and i know something about that because
i actually have watched some of the
olympics olympic events
not really my choice but my wife is a
big she's a big olympic
fan of the olympics and so
i said on friday okay i'll sit down
with the family and i'll watch some of
the olympics
because i'm a family man and
you know i want to be selfless
and so i'll sit down and watch it and i
did
but i spent the whole time complaining
about the olympics and making fun of it
and my wife
pointed out after the fact that that
doesn't really count as quality time so
the next day i sat down i said i'll
actually watch them and i tried to watch
them i tried to endure it
fortunately i missed this though we
didn't watch the opening ceremony
so i didn't have to at least
live i didn't have to endure this
the olympics began with a performance of
the song imagine
[Music]
and it was performed by john legend
keith urban um teamed up for this
atrocity
and now i'll subject you to some of it
here it
must
is
i'm a dreamer
but i'm not the only
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one join us
[Music]
[Music]
and the world will live
in the world
[Music]
okay
it's become popular
to hate
this song imagine
and i'm not gonna be the contrarian on
that i hate it too it's one of the worst
songs ever written
and i was saying that before it was cool
to say that all right it's like the last
couple of years everyone hates this song
but but for most of my
life i've had to endure this song over
and over again
this is supposed to be this
inspirational anthem
and now suddenly people are saying you
know what it is a pretty bad song and
and i'm glad we're all on the same page
with that
and
it's it's sort of hilariously
inappropriate especially for the
olympics because one of the one of the
lyrics is imagine there are no countries
well the olympics is all about the fact
that there are this country is competing
with each other
in olympics without countries i wonder
how that would work exactly
that's
the whole point of the olympics are the
fact that there are countries
and then you look at all the other and
it's not just the lyrics which makes the
arrangement the melody everything it
makes it to this a grating
ironically unimaginative song
but the lyrics especially imagine there
are no countries
uh
imagine there's no religion no heaven
[Music]
this is a a you know a marxist vision
dystopia
that uh for years many people in this
country who do not share
that worldview
have been convinced to embrace this song
and be inspired by it
imagine there's no heaven above us okay
so we're imagining
that we die
and fade into the the ether we fade into
the abyss
into the blackness of nothingness
everyone you've ever known all of your
family
they're gone they're nothing but warm
food nothing more than that
if that's your claim then okay fine i
know there are plenty of people that
believe that but don't ask me to be
inspired by that
you can't put that into
lyrics
expect me to be inspired i don't find
that inspiring i find that horrifying
so a terrible song and as i said the
olympics themselves the the uh
ratings are significantly down
and i think that has something to do
with the fact that it's the same thing
that the
they went through with football and
basketball last year all the pro sports
where you don't have any audience part
of the experience when you're watching
it on tv
is the excitement i've never felt a lot
of excitement about the olympics but i
imagine the people who do part of that
is
the audience there
hearing the crowd cheer that's a big
part of the experience you take that out
and you have these people
doing gymnastics in a quiet empty
stadium it's it's depressing to watch
and that's part of the reason why the
ratings are down and i also think
in the united states anyway
when you've got women's soccer and other
olympic athletes
um
who
don't appear to have any gratitude
or love for their country and that's not
at all the case
for every olympic athlete many of these
people are very patriotic and i feel bad
for them that they're
that's one of the reasons why
aside from the fact that you're
disrespecting your country
whether it's gwen berry or the or the
women's soccer or any of these other
athletes that are doing this
disrespecting your country but it's also
selfish that you're
you're overshadowing
you're making it all about yourself
you're overshadowing these other
athletes
gwen berry remember she was uh she was
she finished third
and all the conversations about her
not the people who came before her
so you're overshadowing and you're kind
of getting them all lumped in with you
which isn't entirely fair but that's
what's
happened same thing with the nba and the
nfl
not all of these athletes are on
in the nba it seems like probably 99
percent of them are but uh in the nfl
certainly
not all of them
are on board with this
the blm propaganda and all of that
but the ones who've made it political
they've kind of ruined it for everybody
else
and so what was supposed to be the
olympics i guess if you've enjoyed
watching them it's it's supposed to be
about
national unity
we're all watching and cheering for the
same team our team you know we're all
together as a team
[Music]
that has been ruined
in recent years especially this year and
it's sad to see
all right next uh tucker carlson so tug
carlson was was trending on twitter over
the weekend as he as he often does
only in this case he was trending not
because of anything he said it was a
confrontation between him and another
guy
at a fly fishing shop in montana and i
say confrontation really he talked
across it was being accosted that's not
really he was not it was this was not
him confronting anyone
he was apparently at this fly fishing
shop with his daughter presumably
getting some fishing gear gonna go out
on a fishing trip with his with his kids
and this guy who uh his name is dan
bailey comes up to him
uh
we you can't hear much we'll play the
clip though but this was originally
shared by the leftist
account occupied democrats on twitter
in a very celebratory way
say let's make this go viral
leftists were cheering this on they love
seeing this
let's watch the clip first and then
we'll talk about it
i don't even know
i don't care man okay just dude you are
the worst human being you're known to
man
i want you to lose
to this city to the united states to
everything else in this world
i don't care that your daughter's here
what you've done other people's families
what you have done to everybody else
[Music]
so you can hear him say you can hear him
say there uh that
you're you're the worst human being
known to man
tucker carlson in this guy's mind
and a lot of people on the left would
agree
the worst person on earth is a cable
news host
who says opinions you don't like
that's their whole beef with tucker
carlson
they're not they're not alleging that in
in secret he's a he's a serial killer or
something maybe they'll get to that
point eventually but right now they're
not
uh their whole beef is that he has
opinions they don't like
and that makes him the worst person
on earth
you can also hear the guy again his name
is dan bailey apparently you can hear
him say i don't care if you're with your
daughter
now i gotta say
maybe i take this especially personally
because
not just as a fan of tucker carlson but
also as a as an angler myself
i i can tell you this this this is such
a breach in fishing protocol to begin
with
this is when yeah he's not out at the
lake yet but still
you're at a fishing shop you're thinking
about fishing you're with your kid
you're about to go on a fishing trip
this is a sacred space
fishing the whole thing is a sacred
space including the shops too go to bass
pro shops sacred sacred place
you don't bring your personal feuds and
rivalries and politics into that
uh but that's what he did i i could also
tell you another thing if this guy is
he's according to occupy democrats he's
a fly fishing guide dan bailey
that's part of what he does for a job i
guess
i can guarantee you the leftist
vast majority of the leftists who are
cheering this on
they're not in the market for a fly
fishing guide
in montana
and most of the people who are in a
market for the market for a fly fishing
guide in montana they don't want some
deranged leftist
weirdo
who's gonna break them about politics
the whole time
so he's probably just destroyed his
business by doing this and for good
reason
that's the last thing i would want
if i was ever going to get a fishing
guide which which i probably wouldn't
because a big part of the thing for me
is to be out by myself but um
the last thing i would want is a guy
who's going to be doing that
defeats the entire purpose
but when you see uh the left is cheering
this on
when he's out again out with this kid
minding his own business
yeah i i think you see how
there is just no respect this is why i'm
always beating this drum about
we don't have unity in this country
and we're not going to have unity
okay not anytime soon
some some massive fundamental things
would need to change in this country in
order for there to be anything like
unity
and those changes if they ever happen
aren't going to happen anytime soon
and this is one of the reasons why you
see it here
why there isn't unity because there's
just no respect
that guy costing tucker carlson has no
respect for him on any level at all as a
man
that's why you go after a guy when he's
with us with his daughter at a fishing
shop
and all the left is cheering it on they
have no respect for him none
i'm not saying they don't respect his
views we know that they don't respect
him as a person
and it's not just him
if you don't agree with them
if you have opinions that differ from
their own especially if you make the
mistake of saying them out loud they do
not respect you as a person and they
don't think you're worthy of respect
and that's been made really clear
maxine waters remember she said confront
them everywhere you find them make them
make sure they know they're not welcome
and she was talking ostensibly about
people affiliated with the trump
administration but really she was
talking about conservatives
there's no there in order for there to
be some kind of unity there has to also
be
serving as the foundation of that unity
there has to be some kind of elemental
fundamental respect between the two
parties you can't have unity without
respect
i don't agree with you but i but i
respect you as a person
and i have to tell you something it's
not just on their end
i will fully admit i don't respect them
either
if you take someone for example who um
would defend a man's right to go into a
woman's locker room and expose himself
to women and children
someone who who takes that position i
don't respect you
someone who defend the mutilation and
drugging of kids
someone who defends the the mass
execution of 60 million unborn babies i
don't i don't respect you it goes way
beyond i disagree i do disagree with you
but i also i just don't respect you as a
person anymore because of that
this is this goes beyond a mere
disagreement
this is a moral flaw a character flaw on
your part that is so profound that i
don't know how could i respect you
so it's a mutual feeling i think on both
sides
and not exactly
the foundation for unity there
all right uh moving on here we got
alexandria queso cortez i thought this
was was interesting just because of how
contradictory it really was so she was
on with don lemon
last night i believe talking about
critical race theory in schools
and uh explaining why hey if you don't
want critical race theory in schools
it must mean that you you just you don't
care if people are racist why wouldn't
you want people to learn how to not be
racist
let's listen
and to that we should say
why don't you want our schools
to teach
anti-racism
why don't republicans
want their kids
to know
the tradition of anti-racism in the
united states
why are republicans trying to ban books
in this country
why are republicans trying to ban speech
why are they trying to fire certain
professors why are they attacking the
core roots of history in this country
that strays anything beyond what we
already know in fact you have folks like
kevin mccarthy making statements that
sound like he's never even read
martin luther king in his life trying to
ban
books that actually talk about the
history of the civil rights movement and
institutional racism in the united
states so why don't republicans
want us to learn how to not be racist
why don't republicans want us want kids
to know how to not be racist
how to not be racist yeah well um i
don't need speak for yourself aoc that's
not a
it's not a skill that i need to learn
if if you feel like you need practice
you need to go to how to not be racist
lessons
then go ahead and do that
the whole thing doesn't doesn't make it
learn how to not be
racist here's what racism is
got to keep defining the term because
uh there's a lot of confusion on this
point
confusion that's being intentionally
sowed by people like aoc
if you
believe that entire entire race of
people
are inferior to your own race
okay if you would rank races
according to who is inferior or superior
then you're racist that's a that's a
that's a racist view that is racism
if you don't believe that
then you're not racist
you could be a lot of other things you
could still be a jerk you could still be
rude you could still have many other
flaws you'd be kind of the person that
leaves your your shopping cart out in
the parking lot doesn't put it away so
that doesn't mean you're a perfect
person
but that's what racism is
and if you're not that then you don't
need to learn anything about racism
and even if you are that
let's say you do believe that a race of
people are inferior to your own
um
someone like that we're not going to
reach that person
by making racism into into this broad
almost unknowable thing
where you have to go to school for years
and years in order to uh potentially
break yourself of it or to free yourself
from it
that's what that's what ends up
happening here is that
you know
actual racism is a thing that that
exists in the world and not just the
united states and not just among white
people
there's there's no denying the fact that
there are people in the world who
believe that certain races are inferior
to their own
no question
what you end up doing is you let them
off the hook
the actual racist you let completely off
the hook
by
taking this label and applying it to
everyone
and saying that you know white people
are inherently racist everyone is
that's you know actual racists can uh
shake your hand and and thank you for
that for letting them off the hook
but there's another contradiction here
because
what are we told about critical race
theory we're told two two different
things
by the defenders of it
one is that oh it's this esoteric legal
thing and uh you're only it's only in
law school and
we're not no one's being taught that in
in in school we're not teaching kids
that
that isn't happening this is this is a
conspiracy theory
this is hysteria on the part of the
right this has been invented by fox news
and uh
conservatives and so on
so we're told that
but then also aoc says i don't know we
we need critical race theory
so if you're if you're criticizing
critical race theory the problem isn't
that you're criticizing something that
doesn't exist
notice that we need it because there are
millions of
of inherently racist little kids out
there and we have to beat that racism
out of them intellectually or perhaps
even physically who knows
it's got to be one of the other doesn't
it
i don't see how it could be both
either it's
this abstract esoteric thing that we
don't have to worry about and you're not
it's not in school it's only in law
school
or it's deeply deeply necessary because
there's so many racist people and they
have to be taught how to not be racist
which one
can't be both
um
i guess we'll play this also
fauci i i was i was hesitant to play it
because this would be like the third day
of playing fouchyclips but
we do have to start paying attention to
fauci again unfortunately
as we see the push to reinstate mass
mandates
as as that gets more and more serious
here's fouchy on cnn talking about that
possibility i want to ask you sources
are telling cnn the top health officials
are weighing whether to revise
mass guidelines for vaccinated americans
are you part of those conversations and
if so what are you advising do you think
masks should be brought back for
vaccinated americans
you know jake this is under active
consideration if you're asking about
part am i part of the discussion yes i
am
part of the discussion but i think what
you are seeing even though as of our
conversation at this moment
the cdc still says and recommends that
if you are vaccinated fully
that you do not need to wear a mask
indoors however if you look at what's
going on locally in the trenches in
places like la county the local
officials have the discretion and the
cdc agrees with that ability and
discretion capability to say you know
you're in a situation where we're having
a lot of dynamics of infection so even
if you are vaccinated you should wear a
mask that's a local decision that's not
incompatible
with the cdc's overall recommendations
that give a lot of discretion to the
locals and we're seeing that in l.a
we're seeing it in chicago we're seeing
that in new orleans because the
officials there many of them are saying
even if you're vaccinated it's prudent
to wear a mask indoors so that's a local
decision
uh that's a lot of words
getting us to the point where
yeah we're gonna see mask mandates
they're gonna try we're gonna see this
again nationwide mark my words that's
what's gonna happen
um
but we talked before about how
you know the the left-wing mob it has
a certain amount of the power that it
has it only has that power if you if you
give if you grant them that power over
you
similar thing can be said here
these mask mandates
proliferated across the country and they
stayed in place for months and months
and months
largely because people cooperated with
them
people showed a willingness to do that
to do as they're told put the cloth on
their face even if they think it's
ridiculous and there's no reason to do
it
so if we once again decide to cooperate
then yeah if we show a willingness
to cooperate then yes
people will be wearing masks across the
country yet again
and it will never end
so it's up to us to decide are we going
to cooperate with that
my answer by the way is no
all right before we get to reading the
youtube comments it's been a little
heavy let me let me read at least one
story
something a little bit lighter but also
really important this is from nbc it
says gen z's now nostalgia for y2k
fashion is leading to a thrifting
explosion
it says recently the hottest piece of
jewelry among gen z's favorite
celebrities has nothing to do with
precious stones or storied retailers
instead stars like singers dua la
who is that
olivia rodrigo and the actor pete
davidson are donning beaded necklaces
reminiscent of homemade friendship
jewelry from the early 2000s
it's part of a rising trend of y2k
fashion and what has been called now
stalgia among gen c gen z who are
reviving or reliving early 2000s fashion
trends they were too young to experience
or remember the first time around
uh so we're seeing a lot of this stuff
that i grew up with is now in fashion
again basically apparently
but i just wish that gen z would would
talk to us millennials before deciding
which of our early 90s or you know our
90s early 2000s fads
should come back
like talk to your elder statesman we've
been we've been there we know we've done
this
definitely don't bring back the baggy
jinko jeans those are done
you want to bring back pogs and yo-yos
sounds good to me if you want to bring
back track suits i'm going to have to
say no to that one
i'm saying no to friendship bracelets we
don't need to do that
don't even think about it with gel pens
you want to bring back
gak um if you want to bring back those
little finger skateboard things
that we all used to have as kids i'm
down with that too
also let's bring back cargo shorts
maybe cargo shorts were never in style
but they've always been in style in my
heart anyway
this is what upsets me
it feels like appropriation when i see
the kids today dressing like we dressed
20 years ago without asking us first
number one for permission
to take our to appropriate our culture
and number two whether you know
a little bit of guidance
humble yourselves kids
now i'm going to tell you about one of
my favorite sponsors beard supply
listen it's july we're getting into
august it's really hot this is when we
separate literally the men from the boys
this is when we find out if you're
serious about growing a beard and
keeping one if you really want to be in
the bearded community because i feel
very strongly about this there are a lot
of people that say oh it's it's november
let me let me grow a beard now and i'll
shave it off
in june
because you know it's too hot that
you're not part of the community i want
to make that very clear
um real bearded people they care keep
that beard year round and you just
suffer with it because it's worth it in
the end it's character building
but if you're going to have that beard
especially when it's all hot and sweaty
out that's all the more reason to keep
it tame and looking fresh no matter how
humid or dry your summer is turning out
to be
and that's why you need to go to
beardsupply.com
uh trust me you don't want to show up to
your neighbor neighborhood barbecue in
the blistering heat without a bit of
beard oil to keep your beard in check
especially with the humidity that's what
the beard oil is all about
and if you visit beardsupply.com right
now you can get a for a limited time you
can buy one beard oil product and get
another one for free so go visit our
friends at beardsupply.com today order
yourself two beard oils for the price of
one again that's beardsupply.com where
you get two beard oils for the price of
one
all right let's move now to reading
youtube comments uh this is from
dh says if the catholic church truly had
any moral authority they would prohibit
pelosi biden and their ilk from
participating in any catholic services
or sacraments
well i as a catholic i do believe the
catholic church has more authority but
you're right that they should exercise
it by prohibiting people like pelosi
biden and their ilk from receiving the
sacraments
and uh and
this is this is one of the big problems
with the catholic church not exercising
authority or rather the bishops
in these dioceses not exercising that
authority
because it looks like
you as the authority figure in the
church you don't take this seriously
if you don't take your own faith
seriously the faith where you're in a
leadership position as a shepherd of
souls if you don't take it seriously why
should anyone else take it seriously
we talk about the real presence of
christ in the eucharist
that that that's
quite a significant and profound claim
um but if you don't take it seriously
yourself then why should anyone believe
it is the thing i think there are a lot
of
non-believers a lot of people outside of
the church that are looking at that and
saying well you know they don't appear
to really take this all that seriously
this goes beyond the catholic church i
mean look at all these churches for a
year that just shut down shop because
they were told to
without much resistance
a lot of
secular people non-believers atheists
who maybe could have been reached before
that
they look at that and say well i guess
church isn't all that important to you
guys
why should i care
it's a serious problem it's a serious
scandal and you lose people you lose
potential converts
shock monkey radio says urinals are the
reason there's never a line for the
men's room
uh yeah i i get that a lot of urinal
defense in the comments which is kind of
weird to me
some people taking this
the urinal thing way too personally
defending urinals
i get it i get that it's it's more
efficient that way i just don't like
being treated like an animal that's all
um
another another question says matt what
do you think of the trailer for the new
neil blom camp film demonic and the
catholic church commandos who hunt them
uh i haven't seen it but catholic
commandos hunting demons sounds
incredible then again this is hollywood
so anything that deals with the catholic
church i'm highly skeptical
marina says everything okay matt you
seem to be having an off day
wow well i guess you don't like the show
on friday i i actually liked the show i
thought i was
i felt great about it until i read that
comment so thanks a lot
this is like when you're out somewhere
and you're feeling good about yourself
feel like you're looking good and
someone says you're okay you look tired
nothing more deflating than that
especially as someone who perpetually
looks tired like myself
amy says my parents always told us life
isn't fair it's a good lesson for life
it's a cliche but it is an important
lesson it's one of those cliches that
that we all heard from our parents that
is
a cliche for a reason because it's
repeated often because it's true
i think another parenting cliche that's
kind of gone out of fashion recently i
don't know if my generation of parents
they don't say this as often but my
parents said it all the time
that's the classic because i said so
now you can you can abuse because i said
so you could say it way too often
but that is an important lesson for kids
to learn
that even if you don't understand why
you're supposed to do something
that doesn't mean you have to you don't
have to do it you still have to respect
my authority as a parent
and we know kids they ask why for
everything anytime anytime you say
anything to them they're always going to
ask why
and so my policy is if they're asking
why sincerely
like they really want to know
um then i'll tell them
or if the why is an important part of
the lesson so i'll say don't run in the
street why oh because you're hit by a
car you know
but many times the why is just a form of
defiance it's just the way your kid's
way of letting you know that they don't
like that you told them to do something
and that's where the because i said so
comes in
that's your message that okay you might
not like it you might not fully
understand it because there are a lot of
things about the world you don't
understand because you're a kid
but i'm the adult i'm the authority
figure and you're gonna respect that
authority because i said so
um and finally linus says this is the
first time i've watched matt from the
beginning
the first time i've watched matt from
the beginning period
and
what did you think see you guys are
killing me with the veiled insults today
i admit this happens a lot where you
know i i see someone and they go uh oh
you're matt walsh from the daily wire
and i say yeah
and they go oh yeah i've seen your show
that's it walk away
which is another way of saying
you're horrible
yeah because if you liked the show you'd
probably follow that up with i saw your
show it was pretty good
in other words i'm deeply offended
if you haven't already ordered a
signed copy of ben shapiro's newest book
the authoritarian moment then you're
running at a time to get that because
it's hitting bookshelves tomorrow
tuesday uh july 27th you can get your
limited edition signed now for just 30
at dailywire.com
ben it's a pretty good deal if you ask
me especially because ben will be doing
a live stream book signing and q a
tomorrow and you can submit a question
right now when you go to purchase your
signed copy when you do you'll be asked
to type in a question at checkout then
you can catch tuesday's live signing to
see if he answers your question and
watch him sign your book if he doesn't
get to your question don't worry you'll
still receive your signed copy so what
are you waiting for you've already
waited all these many weeks we've been
telling you about it well now's your
chance go to dailywire.com ben right now
and order your copy today also we just
launched our newest podcast morning wire
and it's already number two on the apple
and number 11 on spotify why is it doing
so well because it's a daily news
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're proud of what
sticking to our values can accomplish we
need you to help us get the word out to
more people and get this all the way to
number one so subscribe now to morning
wire on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to podcast and leave a five star
review if you like what you hear brought
to you by daily wire editor in chief
john bickley and co-host georgia howe
morningwire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture and education all with a heavy
emphasis on the facts in 15 bite size
minutes perfect for your daily commute
it's just it's a really well produced
show i listen to it uh so i can figure
out what what the heck i'm going to talk
about on my show you should listen to it
as well so again subscribe to morning
wire and apple podcast spotify and
everywhere you listen to podcasts so you
don't miss a beat now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
here are a couple of general rules which
may not apply all the time but do seem
to apply in this case the first is that
bipartisan legislation is the worst kind
of legislation if there's any idea any
proposal that can bring both republicans
and democrats together and put them on
the same page with each other
you know it must be uniquely terrible
the second rule is that when it comes to
long-standing personal disputes between
people especially people who are close
to each other especially family members
if you know only one side of the story
then you don't know the story
your opinion on the subject will be
therefore basically worthless
now with that groundwork laid let's
begin with republican representative
nancy mace who along with democrat
charlie crist and their bipartisan gang
of legislators are pushing a bill which
they have dubbed the free brittany act
this obviously stems from the outcry
over the conservatorship of britney
spears who was denied
the right to make legal decisions for
herself after the court determined that
she's not mentally fit to do so
this decision was made over a decade ago
i think like 13 or 14 years ago
following a very public mental breakdown
actually a series of mental breakdowns
by britney spears and for the past many
years that decision has been repeatedly
affirmed by the courts
the courts have said that britney spears
is mentally unfit
and potentially a danger to herself or
others
but britney's fans and now the public at
large after seeing a new york times
documentary on the subject
have decided that the courts got it
wrong they have declared that britney
spears should be freed from her
conservatorship which had granted
decision making powers to her father
instead of herself
brittany herself now is also calling for
the arrangement to be terminated
and now our lawmakers never letting
ill-informed hysteria go to waste have
jumped into the fray
many republicans have still not said a
word in defense of the january 6th
rioters who've been locked in prison for
months on trespassing charges even as
blm militants who burned buildings and
assaulted police officers go free
and yet
those republicans still have time to
worry about britney spears to that end
here is nancy mace making her case on
fox news here it is
thank you arthel for having me on this
afternoon the free act well first of all
i want to thank britney spears it took a
lot of courage for her to come forward
in a very public way as a celebrity and
public figure detailing the abuses of
her conservatorship just last month in
june
and her situation is a total nightmare
and if it can happen to her of all
people then it can happen to anyone
and what this piece of legislation would
do would allow someone like brittany
who's in a conservatorship
to petition a judge petition the court
for an independent or public guardian
someone that could oversee the
conservatorship who doesn't have a
conflict of interest financial or
otherwise that's really at the crux of
this and there are 1.3 million people in
conservatorships across the country
today
okay
so there are two basic questions to be
dealt with here one is whether this
legislation is needed or warranted
and the other more broadly is whether
britney's fans and instagram followers
and people who saw new york times
documentary are correct in their legal
assessment of the case and their
psychological assessment of britney
spears
so we'll look into both of these
questions beginning with the first
do we need this legislation
well mace and lots of people in the free
brittany movement have echoed this claim
as well
may says that this is a larger problem
she says that conservatorship abuse is a
widespread issue in this country we got
to do something about it but she also
says that 1.3 million people are under
conservatorships
well in a country of some 330 million
people that means if my math is right
and it usually isn't
that what point three percent of all
americans are under conservatorships
not knowing anything about any of those
cases 0.3 seems like a rather
reasonable figure at first glance
is it possible that 0.3 of americans are
mentally unfit to make decisions for
themselves uh yeah clearly so if
anything it seems that the number should
be significantly higher than it is
i'm a little bit upset that it's not
larger than that
a better question is is it true that
that only point three percent of
americans are unfit to make decisions
for themselves only point three percent
now may says that if it can happen to
britney it can happen to anyone
but it doesn't happen to anyone it
doesn't happen to hardly anyone it's
happened to only 0.3 percent of the
country what do you mean it could happen
to anyone yeah but is it
no i'm not arguing
that there's no need for
conservatorship reform what i'm arguing
is that the facts about britney spears's
case what little we know and the fact
that 1.3 million people are subject to
these arrangements
don't themselves add up to a need for
sweeping reform
if a better case can be made then mace
should make it if there is some real
far-reaching serious problem with the
way conservatorships are handled in this
country then present the facts and make
your argument but then if that
far-reaching serious problem exists
why did you wait for britney spears
to bring this up
why are you basing this on the britney
spears case why do you bring this up
before
see there are a lot of people who are
today pretending to be experts on
conservatorships oh you know this is a
major problem in this country yeah it's
a big problem yeah but you never
mentioned a word about that until
britney spears was in the news why is
that
if it's a big problem where was your
conservatorship reform movement before
this
as for the spears case specifically
is it true that she's being oppressed
and abused by her conservatorship is it
true that the courts ought to free her
before we can answer that if we can
answer it
we should establish one thing
it is certainly possible in principle
for an adult to exhibit behavior which
would lead to them losing the right to
make decisions for themselves severely
mentally ill people exist
dangerous and suicidal people exist
that's why we have mental institutions
that's why we have conservatorships
the way some people are talking about
this case it's as though they object in
principle to the very idea that any
adult should be deprived of the right to
make decisions
like the way that they say oh she's an
adult she should make decisions well yes
but what if she's crazy
are you saying that no one should have
their decision-making power taken from
them at all
well if that's your argument
then you're arguing for the abolition of
all mental asylums and psychiatric
hospitals you're arguing that any person
no matter how disturbed no matter how
erratic or self-destructive should be
permitted to continue making choices for
themselves even if those choices are
almost guaranteed to lead to them
harming themselves or other people
or their own children
now you're free to make that argument
but it's an absurd and stupid argument
and not one that any intelligent person
should take seriously
rational people can see
that dangerously irrational people exist
and sometimes on rare occasion remember
we're only talking about 0.3 percent
here
steps must be taken to bring them under
control for their own safety and the
safety of others
if we've established that if we can
agree that conservatorships exist for a
reason and should continue to exist
then the only question is whether
britney spears should be under one or
not
in order to say no to that question we
would need to have evidence compelling
evidence
that she is mentally competent
do we in the public have that evidence
no
what do we have
we have her instagram page where just
this weekend she posted topless pictures
now that's not illegal
i'm not saying anyone who posts a topic
topless picture should have their
decision-making rights taken away from
them
but is it a normal and rational thing to
do when you're in the middle of a legal
battle over your conservatorship
you're posting naked pictures online
is that something that a normal
healthy-minded person does
but we have that
we have a documentary produced by the
new york times in which spears spears
fans and spears advocates and
lawyers unaffiliated with the case were
interviewed
and we have brittany's own public
statements
okay that's that's that's all the
evidence we have to support the
assertion that she is mentally competent
in other words we have nothing we have
no evidence
do we have evidence that bernie spears
should be under the conservatorship
well yeah we do
we know that spears had multiple
psychotic meltdowns in public i mean we
saw it happen so that's how we know it
happened
we know that spears was not granted
majority custody or even half custody of
her children which is a profound
statement in and of itself if you know
anything about the way family court
works especially in california
for a woman
to get like a 70 30 arrangement or she
might have lost custody completely
whichever it was she did not have even
majority custody for that to
happen there's got to be something
really wrong with that woman
we also know that every judge that's
looked at the case and examined her
psychological evaluations have found
that she's mentally unfit
does all of this mean that we in the
peanut gallery can conclusively
determine that britney spears should be
under a conservatorship no
we can't conclusively determine anything
because we don't know her
and we don't know the case
and we don't have access to almost any
of the relevant information
i keep hearing from people oh we grew up
with britney spears we know her i didn't
grow up with britney spears you grew up
watching some music videos of her you
did not grow up with her you don't know
her
but the facts what little facts we have
access to would seem to be leaning
pretty heavily against the free brittany
movement
a movement again spurred on by people
who have made utterly baseless legal and
psychological determinations
a bunch of fans with free britney signs
have just decided that britney is
mentally fit
they have absolutely no evidence to
support this claim none at all
but let's say the british should be
under conservatorship let's just say
that
let's say that she's mentally
incompetent and a danger to herself or
others
would that automatically mean that
nothing abusive is happening to her
under the guise of this legal
arrangement no
she claims for instance that she is
forced to use an iud and not allowed to
have any more children that would be a
horrible injustice but then again the
key word here is claims
she claims that this is happening
the only evidence we have of this claim
is the claim itself which she made to a
judge recently here's the full
transcript of that moment i'm going to
read this to you so when you hear this
thing about the iud this is where people
are getting it from this is the only
place they're getting it from
here's the transcript where she mentions
that to the judge
she says
team wants me to work and stay home
instead of having longer vacations
they're used to me sort of doing a
weekly routine for them and i'm over it
i don't feel like i owe them anything at
this point they need to be reminded they
actually work for me i was supposed to
be able to i have a friend that i used
to do aaa meetings with i did a for two
years i did three meetings a week i've
met a bunch of women there and i'm not
able to see my friends that live eight
minutes away from me which i find
extremely strange i feel like they're
making me feel like i live in a rehab
program this is my home i'd like for my
boyfriend to be able to drive me in his
car and i want to meet with a therapist
once a week not twice and i want him to
come to my home
because i actually do know that i do
need a little therapy laughing
i would like to progressively move
forward and i would want to have a real
deal i want to be able to get married
and have a baby i was told right now on
the conservatorship i'm not able to get
married or have a baby have it i have an
iud inside of myself right now so i
don't get pregnant i want to take the
iud out so i don't so i could start
trying to have another baby but this
so-called team won't let me go to the
doctor to take it out because they don't
want me to have children any more
children so basically this
conservatorship is doing way more harm
than good
so she complains that she wants longer
vacations she wants to go to therapy
once a week instead of two and she wants
her boyfriend to be able to drive her
then at the end as an aside she just
throws in the claim about the iud it
doesn't explain how this even works did
they physically force the iud into her
and what if she goes what if she goes to
the doctor to remove it will the doctor
actually refuse to do it
doesn't bother to explain
she doesn't seem to think that the iud
issue is as important as the fact that
she isn't allowed to take longer
vacations
perhaps the claim is still true
but who knows
well someone knows
she knows her dad knows
the judge might know
i don't know
neither do you
in fact you know almost nothing about
any of this
and the same goes for me
that seems to be the overarching theme
here
a bunch of people who know almost
nothing and have no evidence of any kind
and have access to none of the relevant
information
have nonetheless made sweeping
determinations and are now calling for
legal decisions to be made based on
their assumptions
the whole thing is absurd and strange
and embarrassing
and we have more important things to be
worried about in this country
and for that reason i must say
that the free brittany movement is today
canceled and we'll leave it there
on a note that i'm sure we'll find wide
approval
in agreement
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by nika geneva and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
john bickley here editor in chief of
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the biden
administration signals a push for
renewed mask mandates and vaccine
boosters
australia erupts in protests after
another round of lockdowns and the nfl
experiences blowback to its new vaccine
rules
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morningwire